the lecture processing project is really
all about letting people search inside
videos conventional search engines are
text-based so Google or Yahoo things
like that you type in your text query
and you find the documents that you're
interested in that's great but with
video you can't do that and we're living
in an era where there's or more videos
are becoming available but it's hard to
find four little snippets that you might
be searching for inside the video so
we're using speech recognition
information retrieval technologies to
help process the videos so that then
people can search them using
conventional text-based mechanisms the
way we process a lecture is a series of
steps first we actually chop it up into
little ten second increments and then we
run a phonetic recognizer over these
chunks to find out where the speech is
once the speech has been recognized we
put all the pieces back together and
then we can index it with a conventional
text based a search engine my group
starts processing these materials once
we have actually speech transcribed into
text and what we are doing is trying to
find structure in it because if you have
textual material like retail you have
sentences and paragraphs in sections
when you look at the transcript you
don't even have sentence boundaries so
in order to be able to support efficient
retrieval you need to know what is a
proper units of demand you know user
asks are no recursive function know
which but to show to him so our goal is
to find the structure in the text in the
transcript so we have a publicly
available site and when you go there it
has a video field but it also has a
conventional text field where the user
can type in the keywords are interested
in a perhaps select a subset of the
courses they want to search on so if
they type in the query terms they'll get
a set of hits showing the lectures that
somewhere in the lecture the keywords
that they were looking
for occurred if they find something
they're interested in they can click on
any word at any point and it will start
the video up at that exact spot and
below it you'll see a synchronized
transcript moving along with a video
just showing the output of this cage
rattle the left sight of that piece of
plastic is only positively charged so
here it is the system so far had around
2 million kids we were surprised to find
how much people like it and they really
want to have it expanded in the
following directions so they can
download their own lectures right now we
have a pre-recorded set of lectures we
just let excess in we got requests from
all parts of the country ranging from
doctors to legislators who are asking us
to use similar tools for their own video
libraries I think the technology has two
major applications one is for
accessibility so for example for
hearing-impaired students video by
itself is not that useful so if you had
text to go along with it that would be
very useful for people also very useful
for non-native speakers who might have
trouble following a speech there is
another I think interesting direction is
to try to sort of solicited health from
users to improve the transcripts because
recognition would never be perfect like
in the next 10 years there always will
be some mistakes and it would be really
cool if they the same way as Wikipedia
is created when just users are adding
their material so they can do the same
Corrections for lectures and maybe add
their notes and and whatever information
they found useful so it's like sort of a
you know sauce where which is evolving
and improving all the time